oggi andremo a fare la grandissima
richiesta lo slime da bendandi seguite
la sanzione imposta fate chiuso foto uno
slam da ben nota ma era sola non era
compito e abbiamo fatto un disastro
perché avevo versato tutto il palazzo
quindi oggi vedremo che vita stato
abbineremo assieme lo segnalo times
avventati o paure che farei musica altro
sul tavolo si bruciano che pulisce chi
perde la challenge cup
lei sa chi perde natale vorrei alla fine
del figlio dovrebbe votare questo la cia
e vinco io ho servizio è vitale in base
alla bellezza dello sla e mettetevi
comodi ripetete un bel mi piace se
volete vedere altre challenged line con
degli amici poi appare in quei commenti
giù nei commenti così brutta evitiamo
subito siamo pronti a rimanere il dati
per il talento che tutta la squadra sta
stretto ma non è capito niente
io ho paura che metto tutti gli appelli
per l'accordo
ok allora vediamo stato conosciuto carlo
questo questo 90 offriamo un master e
cerca tutto qualcosa sta sento non far
ricadere viene addosso mi raccomando
casa diverse perché sarah non perfette
sparagli non so cos'è questo questo
potremo scegliere non lo soffrono e 8 no
questo no non mi piace come se queste
cose ma possono essere un numero
illimitato di cota certo poi mettere
tutto quello che vuoi tu non funziona
che cos'è non lo so lo scrivono spesso
buona secondo te i suoi entrato la
ciotola c
questo è facile se beccuccio pure allora
io non so che cosa ho preso una strada
che ne so secondo te ne colore barra
asti allora è meglio prolassi io prendo
questo sei sicuro
perché tu lo vedi che cosa hai preso
magari hai preso un colore sbagliato
verso un polo l'art
[Musica]
ma niente mi faccia mostrano prendere
questo ma allora la cosa in mano
non mi ricordo dove un masso lazio ecco
i due c'è tutto sotto controllo
che cosa stai facendo non provengono di
sentire poiché prendo l'altro vediamo
questo non lo fa per niente fosse così
come capitano come capitano cosa pensi
di aver preso adesso uno shampoo penso
no questo lo shampoo membro notion io
finora ho messo solo una volta proprio
mischiarla che so se riesco a centrare
l'assalto sacco di questo c'è chi non lo
so voglio qualcosa di colorato e ti sei
messo tutto dalle due parti sicuramente
corsa un altro colore mette muro questo
ricorso
ma se queste si affronta tv ha
profondamente salvo così non ho capito
se è riuscito non lo so io sono
impegnato a cercare tu che stai facendo
sto cercando qualcos'altro da aggiungere
roseline che cosa hai messo fino adesso
ho messo una cosa che sto cercando
un'altra ma lo schieri si parli così
strano così siccome noi messo qualcosa
nel mio studio
no faccio tutto neanche dov'è
non mi fare il solletico tutto fare che
cosa potrei aggiungere questo mese di
chiamate le mani anzi no questo è questo
e qualche colorante perché che forma
tubolare tv ma sicuramente sarà qualche
crema che si fa bene lo slide insomma la
moglie problema ma perché ha fatto di
così bello come strumento giusto sono
riuscite a trovare qualcos'altro che ho
messo due finora sono riuscito a mettere
solo un paio di cose ma cosa è aperta
questa volta a giudicare da su valle dei
re lisi no niente stavo cercando una
quota
forse ho preso qualcosa di interessante
che cosa imprese del resto non lo so una
forma ma perché questa con lettura ma
sicura che ha aperto non e via non sto
uscendo no non lo so come faccia sapere
che cosa e ma anche molto duro non
riesco noi che esplode tutto il braccio
non lo posso sapere non so cosa hai
poche altre cose poi aggiungere altro
slime un uso perché non sono contenti o
messa sinceramente voglio mettere un po
di questo non mi ricordo se ho messo
questo lo sanno visto un altro
però mi sa che lo avevamo pubblicato
meglio aggiungere un pò le cose no
questo mese di shampoo lo shampoo furono
so se non dà colore
cosa vorresti trovare se questa cosa o
molliccia che io appena portato che non
posso saperlo tutti stai cercando
io so se fanno qualcosa mi sono
spogliato senza una cosa piace che ci
sono adesso niente allora questo qui
però mi sai che qualche pip in m
perché non far rumore andarci piano con
questo perché sbagliato perché non so
quando stavo aprendo di questi dice il
contrario
novi orizzontale e quindi ne sai col
pigmento bisogna metterne un poco e
stavo cercando una cosa ci sono le
giornate di mezzo secondo me l'ho messo
sulla groppa saffi mettiamo questa città
speriamo che ho preso quello lì che mi
piace a me per celestino tv e celestino
ricevere stile utilizzato aspri e io
provo a mischiare un pochettino di nuovo
preso questa cosa appiccicaticcia qui
cos'è la mamma mia
non so che poi toccando questo no questo
non creiamo questione contratto
lavorativo tutti e dico di mantenerlo
colorante né
però forse questo mi sento sempre uno
shampoo no per 8 basta di cercare le
cose mai un ace di comiso sporcato che
cos'è vajenti bene sapere che cos'è
no sono glitter questi ma non mi piace
como non ti piacciono perché lo voglio
vedere che cosa si sia nascosta i nomi
sono la scorsa proprio niente
questo è il castellare alla soluzione
per l'ente possono esserlo già da adesso
si è fatta di cuore
non lo so io non è che sono fisicamente
questo salone vivamente proprio dove
trovare il bicarbonato ha lasciato lo
accendo e stanno cercando di capolago
[Musica]
che c'è dove mi viene esposto il video
non lo sa ma io sto cercando di prendere
qualcosa faccia sei sempre tu in mezzo
[Applauso]
non ho messo da nessuna parte non so
neanche dove sia economy piace
[Applauso]
[Musica]
si può sapere cosa stai combinando
cercando di cavolate che non trovo ma
non voglio aggiungere nient'altro allo
strike basta
[Applauso]
che cosa è successo no questo è sicuro
[Musica]
perché pensavo fosse il play in realtà
se ne sei sicuro tout court e silenzio
forse è il noto cerchiamo qualcosa non
riesco a trovare niente fatto un
cartiglio sul tavolo sta imparando e
roche imparando come potrei barare
[Musica]
allora fammi cercare qualcosa da
nascondere i tempi carballo
ma io sto cercando qualcosa ma ci sei
sempre tu in mezzo come questa cosa
anch'io volevi carbonare epica bando
sono stato pure bravo che telo in
passato quattro giuste non certo
qualcosa non so che allora io oggi
l'ultimo ingrediente e poi e poi mischio
clinker duro un picchiaduro che cosa vi
prometto niente cercava qualcosa che
sento è sporcata la mano che si vede mai
una bella dieta come faccia bene davvero
così bella e ora proviamo ad attivarlo
sotto girando si sta di là non mangiano
sportiva ma a me chiamatemi attivare con
le mani lo sto tirando con le mani
perché cosa ce l'ho ce l'ho mi è
arrivato addosso
[Musica]
18 12 no beh sì a dargli scampo a un
software di scioperi che stai attento a
ciò io non lo so io immagino in base a
quello che hai detto che cosa vedi tu mi
hai visto di hard ed hanno visto niente
montali è una cosa strana dentro e devi
riuscire ad attivarlo altrimenti vinco
io e poi devi pulire tutto e dunque che
mi ha messo la neve finta cos'è la neve
finta perché non si trova più le donne
con che cos'è la vita
l'arresto dei saints ad attivarlo è pure
io sto girando mi sono trovato un po le
mani ma si sta solidificando e che ne so
mica lo vedo ma lo senti come fai a
sporcati continuazione
ma le vai diventi vero palla sbatte la 7
carte per il momento oppure un po si può
dire sul tuo budget da seguire poi
pulire sul tavolo tanto poi dopo esito
perché dovevo come vedo io perché
sicuramente perderei sfrutta prende se
sei riuscita di bicarbonato bene è
sembrato di aver messo tanto quindi
penso io le ho bisogno di un po di
produzione talenti ce l'hai tu le
soluzioni per lei è aperta la sto dando
va bene tieri dai non vedo l'ora di
vedere il suo attivo
questo è quasi pronta pure io no
portando la regia bischero last light
state le cartine mai scontata
tutto il resto abeba che già avevano
usato pure la vittoria del toro quando
lo slice raffrontandolo slam sarà pronta
la mia chissà che schifezza che uccide
c'è un pezzo super duro e tutto il resto
è morbido
beh forse messo troppo bicarbonato per
moggi rotto subito magari non lo so è
mischiato male
[Musica]
e pronto composto ramo io penso che deve
continuare mestiere mi sono sporcato le
mani peggio per te devi continuare
c'è una cosa strana che non ho messo io
come non l'hai messa to certo che lei è
stato però se non vedevi come fratelli e
saper cosa e mezzo è un ego motivo ma il
mio è quasi pronto ma ne saputo qualcosa
cosa può esserci caduto ma riesce anche
ad attivarlo non col televisore e no si
sta solidificando predatrici essere si è
staccato si staccherà anche della mia
mano destra di perdere allora il mio è
pronto e 21 e sicura quasi sei pronta a
tacere la bella allora siamo pronti a
togliere ben 32 via
[Musica]
stranamente non so come sia uscito
questo colore così carino nel tuo tour
chiese ma non capisco che cosa questa
cosa che sono dentro sembra non posso
dire cosa sembra immerso non c'era
un'altra niente meno che è stupido ma
l'ho aiutato benissimo meloni pensavo
che fosse mi deve essere che non hai
evitato molto bene tu e brasiliano batte
proprio club
scherzo ma ci posso credere o di un po
io non esco crederci
sembra che ha piani ma è impossibile
perché io sono stata superata in
territori conti non sapere cosa si è
ribaltato tutto il tempo dopo mai a
sapere perché io ho dato tutto il tempo
perché noi di sventata ma che cos'è
questo disagio che il combinato sul
tavolo guarda abbiamo discorsi guarda
che catalizza anche i cui ha sporcato
tutto il male fatto uno scherzetto mi
hai fatto
non ho fatto proprio un bel niente
saluto a mettere un attacchino andro
l'animo stato supero attento altro che
per la mente il comune più sito comunque
bello non vuole mai chiuso molto novo ci
credo però che l'ho messa io questa
cassetta non è possibile
guarda che brutto sembra che ci è
passato parlino con berlino ha fatto il
bisognino determinato la meno tonica ma
questo verde qui a tutti tatro ara guler
ora di vedere questo video permettete
che cosa hai combinato
non ci credo proprio come è rovinato lo
slime che era già bellissimo bimotore
per vitale che ha fatto dai più bello
che hai fatto l'in vomitino in volta
google news live è bellissimo perché
tutto giallo e arancione
[Musica]
tornano che cosa fare ma tanto stupendo
c'è un comune non credo che il
meraviglioso ragazzi chi vince secondo
voi
io to be to drive è bellissimo già io lo
spiego che cosa è successo a slide
quindi non vedo l'ora di vederlo questo
video guarda voglio proprio scoprire ai
media che porta indietro ha funestato
berlino mentre noi eravamo ben da anni
noi
io sentivo dei rumori strani e più
serrato romano un paio di volte sopra la
mia foto con ieratiche bella addio ai
sacchetti c'era una stanza viso promosso
a buttarmi nel saluto più bello il suo
votate 46 vinco io ho te vince vita
materiale mi piace per una nuova
challenge slime consigliate di altre
sale dell'irs qui che cala per vedere i
nostri altri video